thank you dr narayan for your
kind introduction today's topic as
mentioned would be
molecular testing for the detection and
strain identification of science kov2
i thought i'd put a small introduction
in here about coronaviruses which i
think most of you know what it's about
there are several coronaviruses that
have been around and discovered in the
last 200 years
many of them in domestic animals there
are about
seven of them in humans four are pretty
benign
and have been around causing mild colds
we saw the first
pathogenic more pathogenic strain come
out in 2003 or so with the sarcoid
and then we had the most coronaviruses
and more recently as you all know the
major pandemic with the
the sars kobe 2. so the life cycle for
these viruses is listed in here and i
don't intend to go into details just to
say that they are
single-stranded rna viruses positive
strain
they enter the cell using the ace
receptor and
a protein called s-protein that's on the
surface of
the virus and we'll talk about some of
the mutations in
the s gene and in fact nonviolent
pathogenesis and revolution
uh to combat this thermo fisher
is a worldwide organization and we
have put in a lot of tools and
surveillance techniques to aid
laboratories worldwide we have many
innovative offerings in the kobe testing
space
we also have methods to do reflex
testing for identification of variants
by
sanger sequencing ngs and genotyping
assets as you see there is a diagnostic
component here and then if there are
variants that need to be detected you
can go the
rtpcr route or use anger or ngs
i'm only going to talk about the
detection format and the qpcr
genotyping format today so when
we started off with the pandemic early
in march
there was not much sequence data
available
we therefore decided that to be very
safe we would target three regions of
the virus
a current diagnostic kid i say targets
the orf1 the sg
and the engine so that gives us a lot of
redundancy
in terms of being i would call it
mutation proofing the essay
so variations in one region will still
not
reduce the effectiveness of this essay
so
multiple targeted regions we have a lot
of bioinformatics tools and algorithms
to make sure that
we have extensive strain coverage near
100
we have done a lot of testing in ours to
ensure that the multiplexing is done
right with
design of experiments and other tools
that
are important for ensuring essay
robustness
we also have tested their say for
robustness stability and failure modes
and then put it through an eua
application with
fda and it's been approved and out there
for quite some time
our so we have a large number of systems
out there
and that's one of our strengths in the
sense that there's about
six different instrument formats out
there you're seeing three of them in
here
additionally we have a huge
manufacturing capability
so all of which has been tremendously
useful in making sure that
our essays are distributed worldwide and
not only across the u.s but in many
countries almost all countries in the
world
the workflow for the detection essay is
fairly straightforward we have a
kingfisher
instrument that can be used to extract
the rna from the sample
the eluted material is then set up in an
rt pcr reaction
we have software to analyze the
data that comes out of the instrument in
terms of fluorescence signals
that leads into the code interpretive
software and you get a defined
interpretation
of positive negative and in some cases
some inconclusives
there are controls in there to monitor
process controls to monitor the entire
workflow
and we provide a clear interpretation to
the customers
based on positive calls for at least two
out of the three genes in here
if you get a single gene positive it's
called an inconclusive and you're asked
to
repeat the test we do provide ct values
in here
that are not only a measure of positive
detection but
also can be used to estimate
in a rough manner the amount of virus
sits around
a couple of things we did we have done
several studies comparing our essay with
other essays out there in the market
this is one such study
where we compared it to the the
logic panther fusion and the kobas
essays
as you can see the positive agreement is
around 100
to the negative percent agreement is on
97.5 percent is pretty good concordance
for an essay like this
we did uh test retest some of the
discarded samples
which come up in this study using sanger
sequencing and
as you can see five out of six were
concordant with
what we had and one out of six was
concorded with the rosh cobas essay
and most of these discarded samples
actually come up
in the city range near lod around 33 34
and you know as you know they can work
differently on different days depending
on how much material gets into your
assay so that's
pretty good in terms of performance we
have also been tracking
emerging variants one of the essays in
our
triplex is an sg sa and this
had a deletion in the s gene did impact
this essay
it turned out that this deletion was a
biomarker
in the uk the southern region uk for
reflex testing
the deletion is a marker for the b117
not all deletions are b117 but a large
percentage of them in the southern
region of kent
or in the uk turned up to correlate with
the deletion
so this was useful for a large number of
labs to track this
there are other key variants out there
now the south african variant the
brazilian variant and a few others as
you'll see in the next slide
this is what i took out of a
presentation at the who
it clearly shows that there are
mutations
associated with particular variants from
the uk
south africa and the brazilian variants
one of the things i'd like to point out
is one of these mutations e484k
was not initially found in the variants
that you see in the uk but it's now
there
so these mutations do move around
depending on
you know viral recombinations or other
events or infections
so you're starting to see some of the
mutations in the african strain show up
in
the uk in the b117 background and i
think this needs a lot more study as it
move
moves ahead there's a recent paper from
julio de oliveira's lab in south africa
quoting six other variants that are in
in play so potential implications for
the sarsko to violence is that some of
them
have increased human human transmission
as documented with the 117
they could potentially have different
disease severity
the susceptibility to therapeutic agents
may vary especially monoclonal
antibiotics and
vaccination protocols and they can evade
vaccine immunity so all of this has to
be
taken into account and from that point
of view tracking these variants is going
to be useful
as you can see the data here on this
slide there's some data coming out of
functional studies with human serum
indicating
that the b117 variant
is neutralized by antibodies generated
by
this is a study with the moderna vaccine
whereas there is some
level of decrease in utilization
capability when it comes to
the african variant it's about a six
volt decrease
the authors conclude that the vaccine
will still work well enough to
neutralize
the south african strain as well but we
have to await
other studies that will come up with
other vaccines and some of it is out
there in the
in the public as well
in terms of mutation detection we came
up with the genotyping format
where we have essays that contain two
probes one
is a probe in the fam channel that picks
up a variant and the other one is
a probe in the wick channel that picks
up the wild type and as you can see here
in this this particular plot the wild
type sequences come up for
for a particular variant and i mean the
mutant sequences come up for a
particular variant and the wild type
detection is in below detection limits
we can also use these cluster plots
to define the variant coming up here
from b117 the n501y and b117
and the wild type sequence is coming in
here now this data came to us from
unfortunately that got deleted out came
to us from mark adams at
the jackson laboratory institute so we'd
like to give him credit for that work
we also have data coming to us from
laboratories in the uk for different
mutations as you can see here the same
n501 variant so we pick up the variant
in one channel and we pick up the wild
type in the other channel
so these can be done by real-time plots
or preferably
using these allelic discrimination plots
on two axis
one for one channel one for the other
as you can see here this is another
mutation that's been coming up with the
literature
called n439k this mutation was
flagged in recent cell paper as being
something
that is required for the s protein to
take on
additional variations it's in a large
number of variants
predates the appearance of some of the
mutations like the n501
the e484k that we're all more familiar
with
so again this data is also very early
and a lot of this
is going to come up in more detail down
the road
two other examples here so this is a
deletion e484k
and this one is the figure for the
deletion 6970 that we see in the b117s
the 484k the 510y and the 417
the k417 and are considered to be
critical variants in close to the
receptor binding domain in the s protein
that could be critical
in terms of evading vaccine response the
three of them together
in the south african strain is therefore
much more of a concern
than right now in terms of what's in the
b117
but these variants i believe will evolve
in the future and we may have
you know many more mutations that come
up in these different strains
but critically this is data from our
internal studies where we use synthetic
templates for the wild type and the
variant
and this is studies from the lab in
europe that actually use variants to
separate out the variant call from the
wi-fi call
so we're trying to collect as much data
as we can so we know that these essays
out in the market are robust
from an uh applied by assistant
thermofisher
point of view we have multiple solutions
again as i mentioned
we have the rtpcr qpcr essays that
i talked about for detection and
diagnostics
we have mutation verification essays on
the qpcr formats
which i just talked about showed your
data the genotyping format we can also
do this
by single sequencing capillary
electrophoresis
and then in addition to that if you need
whole genome sequences
you could do it with the saga formats or
you could do it without ion tolerant
formats for
strain surveillance and there's a lot of
emphasis
on that especially in the uk they're
sequencing about five percent of the
variance
just to get a good feel for what the
distribution is
the us is behind on this right now but
i'm sure we will catch up
in the next few months so in summary
the global pandemic due to stars
has infected millions of people as you
know around the world resulted in many
deaths
an additional concern has been the
emergence of variants across the globe
that some of them have increased trans
transmissibility
some may potentially cause higher
disease severity and
obviously you have the possibility that
they escape neutralization by
antibodies so garments pharmaceutical
companies diagnostic companies
have all risen to the challenge to
contain the pandemic by introducing
large-scale testing
test and trade trace plans and
surveillance of genetic
variants and thermo fisher has been
particularly a big part of it
specifically enable the use of
different platforms that we have for
both the detection and genotyping of the
virus
we have also introduced some antibody
based testing solutions and work to
enable
sample collection and vaccine production
effects which i didn't talk about
in this particular presentation here so
with
that i'll stop